if you need to rent a last minute summer
getaway you may be in luck experts say
changes in the vacation rental market
have created more opportunities fewer
people are living in second homes and
owners who bought rental properties when
interest rates were low are now really
primed to rent them out Meg Oliver looks
at this rental glut that could be good
news for you
here along the Jersey Shore the summer
vacation season is in full swing but the
rental market is telling a different
story have you ever had a problem
renting out your house we've never had a
problem or anything not like this so
this is really unusual super unusual to
have Prime weeks open July August weeks
yeah we're usually fully booked I'd say
no later than February Rory steinelle
and his wife have successfully rented
out this Beachside home for more than
two decades we are steps to the beach
we're pretty close we're a couple blocks
so it's prime location prime location
during covet and up until last year he
says demand was through the roof
allowing them to raise prices and fully
book through the summer so how many
weeks do you still have open to rent
we've got about two that's only after
cutting prices there's that debate too
do you want to keep your premium at a
certain level do you want to make sure
you get every night rented how
nerve-wracking is that it can be
nerve-wracking we want to make sure that
we're able to make some money too you
know not just cover our overhead across
the country popular summer vacation
spots like Cape Cod Massachusetts Maui
Hawaii Santa Rosa Beach Florida and San
Diego California have all seen a decline
in occupancy compared to last year 2021
was a record year for the industry and
it was sort of a coveted anomaly and so
we're coming off of those highs Jamie
Lane is the chief Economist at air DNA
which analyzes listing data from
vacation rental giants like Airbnb and
verbo he says an uptick in international
travel and new rentals on the market
have created more options for renters
which means less bookings per host now
we're seeing competition heat up it's
definitely moving more towards a renter
or guest Market of there's the ability
to find deals there's the ability to
book last minute Genie weed is a realtor
who has been dealing with rentals on the
Jersey Shore for more than 20 years and
says this year the vacation rental
market in the area is off by about 15
renters have more opportunities and
options this summer she says this
five-bedroom home a block and a half
from the beach which rents for nine
thousand a week should be fully booked
by now but this year she's noticed more
last minute bookings I'm still getting
calls for availability for July and
August and even into September were you
getting those calls last summer or the
year before yes but there was nothing to
give them this year is a little
different this year we do have options
for CBS mornings I'm Meg Oliver siegert
New Jersey